STEVE: GOOD EVENING EVERYONE
WELCOME TO "THE NEXT
REVOLUTION".
THIS IS THE HOME OF T11 T11
ONE OF THE ESTABLISHMENTS WAS
THAT DIED IN 2018 HE RELEASED
A NOVEL CALLED THE PLOT
AGAINST AMERICA IN WHICH FDR
LOSES THE 1914 ELECTION TO A
REPUBLICAN WHO SIGNS A PEACE
TREATY WITH THE NAZIS IN THE
TRADITION OF CHARACTERIZING
AUTHORITARIANISM AND FASCISM
AS SOMETHING EXCLUSIVELY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RIGHT IN
POLITICS.
CBS NEWS LAST YEAR SAID
FASCISM IS DEFINED AS A
POLITICAL ONE THAT EMBRACES
FAR RIGHT NATIONALISM.
AND THEN TO BE MASSIVELY
ACCELERATED LAST FEW YEARS AND
THE DEMOCRATS EVERYONE IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT LOST OUR MINDS
OVER TRUMP HE IS AN
AUTHORITARIAN BRINGING FASCISM
TO AMERICA AND IF ANYONE WHO
SUPPORTS HIM IS A NAZI THESE
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS THEY
SAID SPIRIT THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF RHETORIC ABOUT TRUMPS
AND TRUMPS POLICY I DON'T
THINK THAT IS A STRETCH AT
ALL.
>> JUST LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN OR
AIR TO WANDER PRESIDENT XI HE
USED THE GOVERNMENT CORRUPTLY
TO GO AFTER HIS PERCEIVED
OPPONENTS.
>> BUT IT WASN'T TRUMP
PROMOTING THE RACIAL
SEGREGATION THAT THE NAZIS
WOULD CHEER BUT THE WOKE LEFT
EVERYONE FROM ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TO UNIVERSITIES IT
WASN'T TRUMP USING THE POWER
OF THE STATE IT WAS THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE BIG TECH
DONORS INTERFERING THE
ELECTIONS TO SUPPRESS STORIES
ON TO THE CANDIDATE IS NOT
TRUMP USING THE POWER OF THE
STATE TO GO AFTER POLITICAL
OPPONENT THAT IS THE BIDEN
REGIME IT WAS IN THE TRUMPET
TOLD THE FAA TO BAN NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS FROM POLICY
FAILURE AND WHAT WE SAW THIS
WEEK IS A TRUE TURNING POINT
ON HOW WE UNDERSTAND THE
NATURE OF THIS BIDEN REGIME.
ON MONDAY BIDEN ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD STOP THE ALLEGED
POLITICALIZATION OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
SOMETHING I NEVER THOUGHT I
WAS IN AMERICA TO SEE THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH POLITICAL
AND THAT IS HE DID IT OVER
GEORGIA VOTING REFORM AND THE
TEXAS ABORTION WHATEVER YOU
THINK OF THOSE THERE IS NO
CONSTITUTIONAL OR LEGAL CASE
FOR THE FEDERAL JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO INTERVENE IT'S
ALL ABOUT PLAYING POLITICS BUT
THIS WIKI BEHIND THE CLAIM
THAT THIS PERSON IS A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST.
>> EVERY MONTH I COME HERE AND
I HEAR THE SAME THING.
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH IF
YOU TRULY MEAN THAT YOU WILL
AND THE MASK REQUIREMENT
TONIGHT.
STEVE: THIS PERSON IS A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
>> WHEN THEY BECOME ACCESSIBLE
TO BE TOLERANT ONLY WHEN
SOMEONE EXPRESSES THE VIEWS.
>> YOU KNOW WHO YOU THANK YOU
ARE BUT IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE
TO SILENCE HER BULLY ON -┘- OR
BULLY PARENTS.
STEVE: AND THAT THIS IS A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST THIS PERSON
IS A DOMESTIC TERRORIST AND
THIS PERSON DOMESTIC TERRORIST
AND AMERICAN PARENTS WHO LOVE
THEIR CHILDREN AND WHAT
NOTHING MORE THAN TO SEE THEM
EDUCATED OR INDOCTRINATED AND
THEN DOMESTIC TERRORIST I KNOW
THAT PHRASE WAS FIRST USED FOR
THE SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION
CALLING ON THE BIDEN REGIME
THAT MAYOR GARLAND SHOULD HAVE
REJECTED THAT WITH THE SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS THAT IS
OBVIOUSLY A MATTER OF LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO BE
CLEAR ALL OF US WHO BELIEVE IN
PARENTS RIGHTS AND FRANKLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTEST
CONDEMN HARASSMENT AND
VIOLENCE AND DISGRACEFUL SEEMS
LIKE WE HAVE SEEN RECENTLY.
BUT MERRICK GARLAND DID NOT
MAKE CLEAR THAT THESE ARE
LOCAL MATTERS INSTEAD HE
INVOKED THE SPECTER OF THE FBI
ONE IS THE ENDORSEMENT OF THE
DOMESTIC TO INTIMIDATE THEM
INTO SILENCE I HAVE SEEN THOSE
TACTICS AND THEN TO USE THE
CITIZENS IN LINE.
AND NOW TO SEE THAT HAPPENING
HERE IN AMERICA WAS BEYOND
BELIEF.
'S IS THE ONLY BEHAVIOR OF A
NORMAL ADMINISTRATION THAT
TRUMP WAS THE ONE UNDERMINING
DEMOCRATIC NORMS OF STABILITY
IN BIDEN WOULD RESTORE THEM.
>> THIS IS PITTING RED AGAINST
BLUE AND CONSERVATIVE VERSUS
LIBERAL.
WE CAN DO THIS.
IF WE OPEN OUR SOULS IF WE
SHOW A LITTLE TOLERANCE.
>> TOLERANCE?
IS THERE ANYTHING MORE
DESTRUCTIVE OF POLITICAL NORMS
IN THE FUNCTIONING OF CIVIL
POLITICAL DISCOURSE THEN TO
CALL YOUR OPPONENTS DOMESTIC
TERRORIST CRACKS REMEMBER WHEN
PELOSI CALLED REPUBLICANS
ENEMIES OF THE STATE?
NOW THEY JUST COME OUT IF YOU
CHALLENGE YOUR VIEWS WE'LL PUT
THE FBI ON YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE
A DOMESTIC TERRORIST ANYONE
THAT DISAGREES WITH US HAS TO
BE BECAUSE WE ARE THE ONLY
TRUE DEFENDERS OF WHAT IS GOOD
AND RIGHT AND NOBLE AND
DECENT.
YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU EVER TALK
TO THEM AND HAS BEEN LIKE THIS
FOR THE LEFT AND CONSERVATIVES
DISAGREE WE SAY THEY ARE WRONG
BUT WHEN THEY DISAGREE WITH US
THEY SAY WE ARE BAD PEOPLE
EVER SINCE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN POLITICS AND IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS IT HAS GOTTEN SO
MUCH WORSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS THE
DIVISIVE HATE FILLED RHETORIC
OF MSNBC WYOMING THEM UP.
WHATEVER IT IS IT HAS GONE
FROM ARROGANT AND
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS TO A MORAL
SUPERIORITY THAT IS
FRIGHTENING GENUINELY CHILLING
BECAUSE ACTUAL FASCIST THINK
LIKE THIS.
BIDEN LET'S TO SAY THAT BIG
QUESTIONS ARE AUTHORITARIAN.
>> THE UTILITY OF DEMOCRACY.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF AUTOCRACY
WITHIN BEING ABLE TO MOVE MORE
RAPIDLY AND SUCCESSFULLY IN A
COMPLICATED WORLD AND
DEMOCRACIES CAN.
STEVE: THE ELITES HAVE OPENLY
RECOGNIZE THE POSSIBILITY
AUTHORITARIANISM IS PRESENT ON
THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT AND
THEN WITH THE ATLANTIC LAID
OUT AND THEN WRITE ON Q
LIBERAL PUNDIT ARGUED IN A
PIECE THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
SAVE DEMOCRACY IS TO REPLACE
IT WITH A ONE PARTY SYSTEM TO
HAVE ANY RESISTANCE THAT'S NOT
CONSISTENT WITH DEMOCRACY SO
NOW AS WE SEE WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT HERE IN
AMERICA TO SEE THE GOVERNMENT
CENSORING SPEECH AND
EXPLOITING EMERGENCY POWER TO
EXTEND CONTROL AS WE SEE THE
GLORIFICATION OF THE STATE AND
THAT CASUAL DISMISSAL AS WE
SEE THE NORMALIZATION THE
RHETORIC AND POLICY AND THIS
WEEK THE MOBILIZATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST POLITICAL
OPPONENTS AND THEN THE BIDEN
REGIME IS A FASCIST REGIME
FASCIST IN THE MINDSET AND
PREJUDICE AND THE
STATE-SPONSORED
AUTHORITARIANISM FASCIST IN
THE DAILY ACTIONS TO FIGHT
TRUTH AND JUSTICE WITH THE
INTEREST OF THE RULING PARTY.
THE BI